Mit dem Zug in die tschechische Hauptstadt:
Prag ist die erste Etappe des Interrail-
Abenteuers von Aedan Gibson aus Edinburgh.
Von den Fassaden in der Altstadt
bekommt der Student kaum genug.
Und natürlich ist auch die
berühmte Karlsbrücke
aus dem 14. Jahrhundert
ein absolutes Muss.
Manches erinnert Aedan Gibson dabei an
seine Heimatstadt in Schottland.
Wir haben auch jede Menge Musik und
Künstler auf den Straßen,
viele Veranstaltungen.
Aber Prag ist völlig anders.
Eigentlich sogar schöner, als ich erwartet
hatte. Die Gebäude sind unglaublich,
wenn man sie mit eigenen Augen sieht. Es
hat sich wirklich gelohnt herzukommen.
Dass er das erleben kann, hat er einem
kostenlosen Interrail-Ticket zu verdanken.
Dafür musste er sich mit seiner
geplanten Reiseroute bewerben
und ein Europa-Quiz beantworten. Eine
Jury wählte dann 15.000 Gewinner aus –
alle genau 18 Jahre alt und EU-Bürger.
Der Schotte sieht sich in der Pflicht.
Wir sind quasi Botschafter dieses Programms.
Hoffentlich wird es das viele Jahre geben,
denn ich glaube, es kann einiges bewirken.
Ich werde meine Erfahrungen
in sozialen Netzwerken teilen und
vielleicht sogar Vorträge halten.
Das ist eine Menge.
Ja, ich bin ein Botschafter.
Free Interrail ist eine Initiative von
Martin Speer und Vincent-Immanuel Herr.
Die beiden Berliner haben bei der
Brüsseler EU-Kommission
für das Gratis-Ticket gekämpft.
Sie träumen davon,
dass jeder EU-Bürger zum 18. Geburtstag
ein Interrail-Ticket geschenkt bekommt.
Das europäische Zugticket zum
Pauschalpreis gibt es schon seit 1972.
Jugendliche, die auf grenzenlosen
Schienen Europa erkunden,
können besser dabei helfen, Vorurteile
abzubauen als manche Politiker.
Diese Überzeugung gewannen
die zwei Initiatoren
natürlich bei einer eigenen Interrail-Reise.
Schlüsselereignisse auf dieser Reise
und besondere Erlebnisse
waren die Gastfreundschaft,
die uns begegnet ist, Leute, die uns
zum Essen eingeladen haben,
nach Hause eingeladen haben,
wo wir von einer Stadt in die andere gereist
sind und Leuten Bescheid gesagt haben,
dass wir kommen. Und diese ganz engen,
vielen neuen Verbindungen, Freundschaften,
die wir geknüpft haben, das war wirklich
Europa für uns.
Und wir haben Europa wirklich mit
neuen Augen kennengelernt
und wirklich verstanden, dass Europa nicht
Gesetze sind oder irgendwie
politische Unionen, sondern die Menschen
in all ihrer Vielfalt.
Viele der 15.000 Jugendlichen berichten
in den Sozialen Medien von ihren Erlebnissen
und Begegnungen quer durch Europa.
Doch schlägt das wirklich neue Brücken?
Kritiker werfen ein, es nütze nichts, wenn
junge Menschen auf ihrem Interrail-Trip
nur die unterschiedlichen Biersorten
probieren würden.
Aedan Gibson hat sich vorgenommen,
auch die Geschichte der Länder zu erkunden,
die er bereist. Im Prager Kommunismus-
Museum erfährt er viel über die Entstehung
der Tschechoslowakei und das spätere
Bündnis mit der Sowjetunion.
Der Kommunismus in der Tschechischen
Republik ist Geschichte.
Allerdings auch bald die
EU-Mitgliedschaft Schottlands.
Nach dem Brexit wird kein Brite mehr ein
Free-Interrail-Ticket bekommen können.
Ich glaube, viele Menschen haben
blind abgestimmt und
sind irgendeiner Propaganda gefolgt.
Wie im Kommunismus.
Und dann muss es doch mal Bier geben.
Ausgerechnet im Heimatland
des Pilseners keins zu probieren,
wäre schade.
Für Aedan Gibson endet nach
zwei Tagen die Prager Etappe.
Interrail – das ist eine Art
Speed-Dating mit Europa.
Kaum hat man einen Ort näher
kennengelernt, geht es auch schon
weiter zum nächsten.
Und das oft ganz allein –
was der 18-Jährige jedoch mag.
Man trifft leichter andere,
die auch solo reisen.
Daraus können leichter
Freundschaften entstehen.
Alleine reisen –
das kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Aedan Gibsons nächste Stationen sind
Wien, Budapest und Ljubljana.
Zwei Wochen durch vier europäische
Länder, bevor es
mit vielen neuen Eindrücken zurück
nach Schottland geht.